foreign
that's for next week that's your clue
for next week yeah
this week we're talking
about I was about to say I'm Lon Harris
but I was looking at you
that's Lon Harris rocking the
barberheimer shirt we're going to talk
about Barbie the movie um I was going to
say inside and out also probably
inappropriate let me talk about our uh
our deepest thoughts about the Barbie
film we're going to discuss it very
superficially I promise surface level uh
deleted scenes uh q a so put those in
the chat if you have any comments or
questions and then we'll tease you with
next week's honest trailer which is what
we were talking about before the camera
started rolling and oh boy I don't think
we're gonna make any new internet
friends no man they're gonna be mad at
us
uh we'll see if we pull any punches or
if they are as long and stretchy all the
punches are very they're pulled like
taffy all these punches okay well you
gave it away but now we're talking about
Barbie uh Barbie was a much balihood
film much hyped
um I think this got a lot of people to
the theater again
Cinema
and she must pay for that
um according to a lot of people yeah
um but I thought this is a funny comedy
movie that I liked and um I didn't feel
uh
uh personally attacked as a man no I
felt able to enjoy the the comedy and
the characters even though they didn't
have genitalia at all I I actually feel
like like for all like they're like yes
there's a lot of jokes about patriarchy
and feminism like obviously it's dealing
with all those issues but I think at
core I don't think the message of the
movie is like dudes are bad or stupid or
all those things people were getting so
upset about it's really like we're all
kind of penned in by these forced gender
roles and these ideas of who we should
be based on superficial stuff like our
biological gender at Birth and I think
you know the movie's kind of saying like
you can sort of free yourself with that
for everybody for men and women hey it
was a
satire where they're taking real
difference and perhaps heightening them
for Comics sure of course it's not a
documentary about about they said no
this is real this is what really
happened this is what's happening in
Barbie land right now yeah so they um
you know they uh
they flipped it they've the the only
like commentary is like what if in
Barbie land guys were treated like
historically girls and girls
historically like guys
and go from there to make jokes I I
agree with what you're saying that I
think everybody immediately jumped to
the like let's write a paper breaking
down the discourse of this movie when
like really
mostly just about being funny I think
people like people can hear so much into
it that it's like sure there are
political points being made it is about
stuff it has ideas but it's like it's
really about being funny primary I'm
sorry I take it back because here's what
it's mostly about and yes this is a
criticism but it's one that can be
levied at truly any film that comes out
of the American Studio system which is
this is about selling Parts
it's an ad for Barbie whatever you
believe and whoever you are there's a
Barbie for you well this is
it's a it's actually a great lesson in
how capitalism sort of commodity like
Steals and commodifies ideas even ideas
that are oppositional to it it like
eventually brings them into the fold
like we can sell that yeah like this is
because because the the uh I'm blanking
on the name Sasha who's the the daughter
like America Ferrara daughter little
Gamora right little Gamora she starts
the movie voicing every critique right
long-standing feminist opposition and
critiques of Barbie that are many of
them very legitimate have been true
until like 2009 yeah and they started
like okay fine there's a lighter there's
a darker shade of Barbie this is the
doll that was like math is hard like
it's the same and and and so she but by
the end of the movie she becomes a
convert she's like no we gotta go save
the Barbies we got to go back to Barbie
line like that that is the movie telling
you the picture put these quit these
critiques aside above all Barbie is good
and you should probably buy some for
your kid it's there for a new generation
um no more brats they can get Barbies
too or do they still do brats I know
she's named after a Bratz doll I think
all of the girls at that lunch table
where they're making fun of Barbie I
think all those characters are named
after the Bratz dolls
their Mattel is making money either way
and the Bratz dolls had their own like
they they had their own raft of
controversies when they were new right
they were like hypersexualized taking
the wrong messages together I don't
expect nor am I let down by the Barbie
movie despite making I don't know uh
nods towards this but at not being like
a uh philosophical antidote too right um
to uh commercialism yeah I mean I think
that's what I mean like when when
reviews come out and people are like hey
this movie is actually like surprisingly
smart and has stuff on its mind and
things to say I think that immediately
gets like overblown into like this is a
philosophical Treatise that everyone has
to like have a have a fiery passionate
opinion on and it's like these are PG-13
movies for children let's be honest
Wittgenstein it is it is a Barbie movie
and like you can just treat it on that
level you don't hat like there is stuff
to pick apart if you want to I saw a
really good uh I saw a really good
YouTube video I think Houston Coley's
the guy who made it about like all the
connections to the Book of Genesis and
this movie like you can you can dig that
deep if you want to because Greta Gerwig
and Noah bombach are smart and they made
a smart movie but you know you don't
have to really this is like mother
well I mean if you think about just like
on the most obvious level like Barbie
land and Eden there's a lot of
comparisons and like you know she kind
of like tastes from the Tree of
knowledge and then it becomes dispoiled
and it is kind of there's a lot like
that I I recommend that video if you
want to go real deep into it but like
that's the kind of core Will Ferrell is
a vengeful Old Testament God exactly
yeah but Mattel right Mattel would be
God it would be judgment yeah cheers to
that uh all right let's watch our uh
honest trailer for the Barbie movie and
uh we'll have more to say then
I guess Ruth would be gone
he's the Creator yeah
[Music]
from not Amy Schumer thank God comes
another Greta gorwig film about a pretty
white girl's quarter life crisis but
this time it's the backdrop to a literal
toy commercial Barbie
welcome to Barbie land a place where
everyone lives by Nietzsche's doctrine
of Eternal recurrence this is the best
day ever you guys ever think about dying
uh I mean a pretty pink neighborhood
where everything is perfect unlike the
toy aisle it's a land where every race
and body type of Barbie is treated
equally as they all copy how they're
being played with in the real world
minus the tides we make them kiss and
match their smooth plastic Mounds
together I do not have a
never stop me
I think that is a crucial
um it's like there's like
four to five things you can do with a
Barbie doll before you're making them
scissor right I mean you're asking I
don't know I never I never play I only
player the manliest of Man toys there's
only four or five things you can do with
the GI Joe before you have just a
construction worker that turned into a
dump truck that was the only thing yeah
got dumped like a truck that guy
um yeah I I just think that that's like
for a movie is knowing and winkies as it
was I guess maybe Mattel is like you can
admit that people like you know make the
Barbie I think I think weird Barbie was
their overall all-in-one nod to like
non-approved things kids do with their
Barbies Okay and like we got one
character that's like I don't remember
you tear their hair out make them look
crazy without the constances right
because how do you work that in without
the movie okay even short of scissors
and you never make Barbie and Ken kiss
like that's not a thing that people play
with their dolls to do I mean I get I
guess it is but well I didn't see you
playing with your dolls again sir
I get I guess it is like it would be a
hard thing to translate into into the
film fair fair you know like I think I
think there's one point where uh the the
little Gamora asks like do big hands
come down and actually like play with
you when you're playing like I feel like
that's one of those things like maybe
that would have been more accurate but
it would also look weird really strange
uncanny release the hand cut The Uncanny
Valley Barbie like the cats version
like Rob Marshall to make the Barbie
movie
yeah how they're being played with in
the real world minus the tides we make
them kiss and match their smooth plastic
bounds together I do not have a
never stop me Margot Robbie shines as
stereotypical Barbie the best pairing of
actor and toy since Vin Diesel stuck his
hand up a street shark
you'll believe every step boss uh I
gotta just say this was one of those
where I feel like the first emails back
and forth of notes about Barbie was just
a competition like who was gonna figure
out how we work in the streets I think I
believe in the uh script we've stopped
putting the actual link to that video
and just say you know the clip No No
need no need but yeah like at the moment
Barbie I was like I was like well
obviously we're working in
it's just contextually how at this point
I would guess that's the fourth maybe
fifth time we've we've managed to work
that clip but it won't be the last until
until Hollywood gets off its ass and
makes Divinity I mean odds are high
there will be one for Aquaman two uh
we'll get a street shark uh thing in
there I mean next week's trailer there
are sharks there are mean sharks sharks
for emotional Journey except the one
time she doesn't feel pretty Margot
Robbie is the wrong person to cast if
you want to make this point in the first
film since Legally Blonde or someone
pink and Gurley wasn't a villain because
the villain role is already taken by man
I mean can Ryan Gosling finally gets to
shake off his sleepy-eyed murder face
and take his back to his Disney door
Crews Gotta Give Me That Pie
in a comedic performance that transcends
funny for someone who looks like Ryan
Gosling
that's fine and approaches funny for
someone who doesn't look like Ryan
Gosling I have all the genitals I hope
the nice guys was a fluke but no there's
really nothing left for us how goes game
over Gus wins
[Music]
yeah pause I mean
some people some people God just gives
with both hands sometimes yeah it's it's
Ryan Ryan Gosling is unfair Ryan Gosling
is unfair and the crazy thing is I I
went through a bunch of those Disney
Mouseketeer clips of him to like try to
find like a good a good thing to use and
like he arrived fully formed he was
already like Ryan Gosling at age like
eight German Canadians yeah I was like
man how would you how are you already
doing your bit like and there's a lot of
uh there's a lot of hunks out there who
they uh cast in comedic roles and maybe
even get laughs but it's because like
they're playing a I guess he was playing
a dumb hunk but um I'm just thinking of
like Hemsworth in the in lady
Ghostbusters or like Chris Evans gets
these kind of Parts sometimes yeah like
like you would you're laughing because
of someone who looks like that saying
that right printed this is Barbie's a
bad example but the other guys or not
the other guys
um the nice guys yeah uh so funny in
that yeah God he's got like genuine like
comic chat like I I even this like he is
kind of playing like the dumb jaw
caricature but there's there's a lot of
layers to Ken in here and he pulls off
the like dream ballet musical sequence
too it's like the Dream Within A Dream
yeah like the same guy shouldn't be able
to do Drive La La Land and this that's
not fair that's not fair I'm not a la la
land Liker but that's fine it's a Blue
Valentine take your pick pick another
weird outside the box there you go all
right keep going
the lawn on Barbie and Ken's trip to the
real world sometimes it's the reality we
live in sometimes it's more zany than
Barbie land
there Ken will speed Ruther the
manosphere like a middle schooler's
first Andrew Tate video
what was that well Barbie will have to
balance handling her new feelings of
inferiority with the superior handling
of the new Chevy Blazer EV get it
I gotta lose these chuckleheads
her discomfort with being judged by her
exterior with the smooth comfort of the
new Chevy suburban's interior thanks for
the ride this has been so much fun my
truck car I'd like to have actually in
this epic Voyage of self-discovery that
wouldn't be possible without first
getting into the 1956 Chevy Corvette C1
it's subtle Like a Rock
aren't the only yes it is a car
commercial I feel like we we made that
point pretty pretty well but uh just
touching on something from the beginning
that's maybe glossed over a little bit
is do you think the satire or the the
message is undercut or not undercut but
muddled by the fact that like
the real world has two has a lot going
on that's not particularly real like she
goes to the real world right and it's as
much of a cartoon as Barbie land half
the time yeah I mean it's the real world
of a Hollywood goofy comedy like I feel
like we like Barbie land is so
heightened that even going to like the
real world of a zany comedy it still
feels different enough that the movie
where like this wasn't a problem for me
but you're right that our reality in in
Barbie is not really practical I guess
it's less the you're right that it's
less the two different realities and
more like it seemed like there were two
overlapping villain plots and you I
don't think you needed Will Ferrell no
you don't need them you definitely don't
need the Mattel Executives and you could
tell because I think I think she wanted
to do that one sequence where they they
originally go there and they try to get
her in the box and she meets Ruth
and then I I don't really feel like
Greta gerweger Noah bombach had any idea
of like what to do with them after so it
ends up being this Chase thing yeah
there's like our commercial stuff in
there you think Will Ferrell's this like
heartless executive who just cares about
money but then his characters like
genuinely cares about little girl's
dreams and that well that and that's
also it's a little piece of satire that
I'm not quite sure it works it seems to
kind of be both things at the same time
like are we making fun of like woke
corporations and like these companies
pretend to be about social justice but
really they're just about selling you
things or is this sincere you know is I
I I it was hard to know how to how to
sort of take out I think at some point
the movie's working on so many layers
that it's like
hard to gauge what level of reality
we're supposed to be at and I think it
was fine to have would have been fine to
just have Ken and Barbie both be I don't
know radicalized or realized from their
trip to the real world instead of that
whole kind of farce of the of the
executives yeah I don't I just I don't
think you need all of the like the
executives going to Barbie land and
showing up at the end and all that chase
stuff it does end up feeling like this
isn't a Chase movie we don't need like
there are so many hijinks going on
conceptually I don't think we need these
like otherwise how are you gonna know
the Chevy bolt EV has a turbo mode yeah
I mean wow there's really like
Mattel didn't give them a nut like
that's where it's crazy it's like Mattel
didn't give Warner Brothers enough to
make this movie Warner Brothers was
still like out there with the with the
passing the hat around like anybody else
Chevy can you please sir Abby can you
help us make a Barbie movie like it's a
Barbie movie just have the people who
make Barbie
to quote Mr Burns I'd trade it all for a
little more dude that's crazy it's like
whether they just not like zaz just
didn't want to pay at all he's like we
could have Chevy pay for the Barbie
movie and then it's pure profit
a whole new bucket of Yachts that's that
says and all that says characters
getting in and out of various Chevrolets
there's Gloria who's show-stopping Mama
law Builds on the ideas first set forth
by a hand with pobodies nerfect on it
are you doing everything wrong but also
everything is your fault her daughter
Sasha a life like Bratz doll who shows
young girls how capitalism subsumes all
critiques into itself you represent
everything wrong with her culture Barbie
Landing saving Barbie needs saving weird
Barbie who's so weird you don't know if
she's gonna do the splits or reinforce
China's territorial claims over Vietnam
Alice Michael Sarah is long overdue
apology for the crimes of Scott Pilgrim
Will Ferrell as Lord Business
by the way uh people are popping off of
the comments like what did Scott Pilgrim
do re-watch Scott Pilgrim he knows what
he did
I mean on the most obvious level he's
like dating a teenager in the beginning
isn't he well what's the well guys
[Music]
like there's some obvious stuff that
he's not doing right great time to plug
the by the numbers on Hollywood age gaps
by the way thank you for that teeing up
that Segway
um I did that on purpose yeah age gap's
problematic or you be the judge um check
that out on Phantom energy what do you
think there was a tweet yesterday that
was like the age Gap in Lost in
Translation is inappropriate like but
there like I do they need to seal the
deal for it to be an inappropriate age
Gap or is like even a like an emotional
affair a weird Crush that you don't ever
do anything about inappropriate I think
that was that's the question being
thrown down there because they're sound
off in the confidence there's obviously
something between those two characters
but it's not like a romance like they
don't kiss and make out yeah she just
like can't stand Spike Jones
once you get like there's like yeah like
there's a little like emotional jealousy
or whatever but they're not they're not
a couple in a traditional sense so I
don't know if you can have made December
discounts you have to have penetration
yeah that's what I'm saying what level
of what level of penetrative sex you
have to have before on screen December
romance becomes an issue got it tell us
in the comments tell us a down dog yeah
all right keep going I love Mattel
whatever and a rousing game of spot the
actor from every British TV show Greta
Gerwig likes
to teach audiences about feminism
oh that's so smart the patriarchy I'm a
man with no power does that make me a
woman and female anatomy I'm here to see
my gynecologist in a fresh new
installment of woke Wars 2K 23 that did
the opposite of go broke in a basic 101
level lecture full of broad
generalizations and naive fixes we're
giving voice to the cognitive dissonance
required to be a woman under the
patriarchy erupted of its power yes
because it's a popcorn movie congrats
you're smarter than a child's doll
here's a student loan
speaking of the installment of low cores
2K 23 yeah that this came out
people said it was going to bomb because
it was too broke it didn't and now they
have to say it's actually secretly
anti-wolf yeah yeah Ben Shapiro's fiery
opening night rant ignore that he was
wrong it's actually very anti it's
actually quite into it I love that but
his his first video is like I didn't
want to come see this my my producers
forced me they made me they dragged me
to come see Barbie he's like you wanted
to see Barbie you knew that you were
gonna yell about it come on don't lie
um I'm just trying to think of more
excuses to do my Jordan Peterson
impression and um has he chimed in on
Barbie yeah I'm sure it was like yeah I
know about this Barbie movie poor kids
living under the femtography they're
forced to do Beach
day in day out
well you can come to my house and force
me to watch this Barbie movie at the end
of a night I won't watch it otherwise
uh up yours up yours Ken
oh it's been it's been up that's begging
to happen someday
um just need a good Kermit the Frog
puppet of course wearing he's got to be
wearing like a two-faced suit like half
oh he has to be wearing like two Hickory
suits that ran into each other at high
speed you know like like you know you
remember Matthew lesko oh yeah yeah
you can get money from the government I
feel like Jordan Peterson's our new get
money from the government that oh man
um your kids are too young for that
reference that's fine look them up keep
going that shines thanks to its
incredible production design perfect
casting and a release date that got them
more Free Press than the Grimace Shake
in one of those hits that should remind
Hollywood women like good comedy too but
Warner Brothers will see the results and
conclude toys they love looking at toys
give me Uno give me Barney give me my
magic eight ball whoa toys
starring
the Pink Ranger Goss and the Real Girl
brand Parenthood when is Gamora Allen
Army mama drama you're just a woman
woman with a small brain brain the third
the size of us it's just science Cynthia
from Rugrats reps
Chong chard C-sections in Barbie Lander
have been excessive ah Aqua every
couple's costume this Halloween every
tick tock this year
[Music]
when you know they had Tarantino
turn your feet yeah
when you know they lost Tarantino I
don't want to touch a foot when they
stuck into film Bros it's like I've been
in a dream where I was somehow really
invested in the Zack Snyder cut of
Justice League and when they went too
far oh my God you've never seen The
Godfather can you start the movie over
and just talk through the whole thing
The Godfather is a masterpiece Francis
Ford Coppola's Mastery of The Craft is
Bianca oh no I'm one of them aren't I
yeah pause I mean I I felt very targeted
by this I uh my wife then girlfriend I
was like you haven't seen the company
and we Godfather one and two I don't I
don't think I talked through them at all
through the viewing but I was like what
you
I don't know if there's a dude who loves
movies who's capable of hearing the
phrase I've never seen The Godfather
without reacting that it's just it's
just baked into US you can't do anything
about it got him
um yeah that that's like I feel like
that's Noah bombach just being
self-aware it's like all right you can
like put this in here because I'm like
this yeah I do think that talking
through a movie is um is a killable
fence but
um yeah yeah definitely first time if
anybody in the room is watching it for
the first time
[Music]
you'd be quiet yeah you let them you let
them experience it the way it's meant to
exactly the first after this is the
first time once you're watching it for
the third time go for it
um there you go uh let's uh yeah let's
wrap it up Guys and Dolls
I have a TV in my back you know whose
dream that is nobody nobody's dream did
they not consult any men on the script
I should have put in the um the George
Costanza scene where he's uh having sex
eating the hoagie man watching
television at the same time it's a dream
uh it's a dream um all right so can I
just say yeah I was gonna comment before
but I didn't want to pause uh what are
the one of the toys that always makes
this headline whenever they're like
Mattel's got a lineup is Polly Pocket
and I'm not sure if this is just me
being a man and like this was not
marketed to me so I don't I I swear I'd
never heard of that before oh yeah that
was a thing was that a big thing it's
Polly Pocket I I remember the
commercials I don't think everybody was
um until they started talking about
we're gonna like late I think Lena
Dunham is making the Polly pie there was
a boy one like I want to say micro Max
um what
it was Max just there was Mighty Max was
a toy but he was very small was it
Micromax or was it uh well there was it
there was a toy named Mighty Max I don't
remember
Mighty Max Mighty Max like those ads I
remember because that's the thing is
like there are a lot of girl toys I
remember the commercials I just never
had them but like I don't remember I
feel like Polly Pocket was like that's
what it's one of those like uh you know
Mandela effect things like this was not
I don't believe you that's not a real I
just remember the commercial story
Saturday morning cartoons
um and Micro Machines is what we're
talking about sure no yeah like that
right like because there were a lot of
you like I was I was writing a video for
another company about uh Dino Riders and
like I never had those toys when I was a
kid but I definitely remember the
existence of Dino rides we are at the
absolute bottom urinal cake of the IP
Barrel at this point so toys really like
other than the biggest ones like we've
done Barbie GI Joe Transformers but even
like Masters of the Universe we haven't
done like I feel like there's a lot of
classic toys that haven't gotten that
just had the Kevin Smith show right yeah
there's right well there's there's
multiple animated shows now yeah no
there's not much left that's like a
yeah like the top line and you can't do
like you know the uh yo-yos like uh like
Lincoln Lincoln Logs yeah right
Stretch Armstrong they've been trying
they keep trying and but I that's
another one where I was like I remember
that being a toy that existed but like
does he have lore does anybody really
care at this point like it's just a name
we should write the stick movie though
because there's nothing cooler as a
young boy than to like find a big stick
a big like a like a well-shaped a
well-shaped it would like could work as
like a weapon yeah
you want it it's got to be it's got to
be walking stick and then like sword
yeah it's got to be but it's got to
cover both of those angles yeah he finds
like the ultimate stick
um but there's a dark stick somewhere in
the forest pretty much every Epic
Fantasy is basically
got it we gotta find the dark stick or
the good the light stick The Stick of
light the bright wand
is that from Bright yeah the bright
they're looking for the it's the bright
one which is a stick that's literally
imagination this could be our Star Wars
um all right thank you that's crazy
thank you thanks for thanks for watching
et cetera et cetera watch uh watch the
bad numbers on this channel
um and uh hit like And subscribe because
we'll be back next week for another one
that you've probably already gave away
let's go to the chat
um
MJ pretzer of all of uh Mattel's other
crazy film ideas what do you think will
work I say the a24 Style Barney movie I
do not agree with that I think that's
gonna be so bad I mean I feel like we've
done this like Barbie did the like you
know modern version take on discourse on
the toy meets the classic toy like we
and and every other movie already does
the like oh you like Woody Woodpecker
well now he's in the real world and it's
like I feel like we're already at the
point where we kind of need a new angle
like what's the new satirical take what
is Stretch Armstrong was a pirate
and it was very violent but also dumb
[Laughter]
can't wait uh what's coming up next week
oh yeah sure throw some outtakes in
there
starring
filminocchio Beach Boy Tata tan
replicant how to train your children
doll in the family the secret Strife of
America's teenager him forever alone
another wimble in the Barbie Ria girlman
Saturday night shouldn't be alive weird
gal swankovic HB Otis Ken's convenience
kensley benedir secret invade Karen a
few good kid toy Meets World
Chad featuring Barbie
listen I know I said we need more movies
about getting high but I meant like half
baked two or something
hi hi Barbie hi
hi Barbie hi
hyper hi Barbie hi Barbie hi Barbie hi
Barbie hi Barbie hi
so does Barbie's real person magic
extend his social security numbers and
backdated birth certificates or is it
just for who has
makes you think
um I'll tell you what made me think
earlier in the film she says she has no
genitals so when she does make this
decision and Ruth is like do you want to
be a woman and she's like yes I want to
be a real human
something
very dramatic happened
how did that feel yeah
all right uh Damien says in reference to
barberheimer which two movies would make
the best all-time opening weekend
matchup or compliment each other I wish
I'd that that's a really good question I
wish I'd thought about it
um because I mean the the thing that was
so fun about this was they're such
tonally they're both good but they're
yeah and I don't want to fall into like
I could pick another boy movie Girl
movie yeah right but it's like that's
not that's not exactly the the whole
deal yeah I don't know
um
seven no seven and Shrek seven and Trek
yeah that's awesome that's awesome track
seven Shrek seven yeah uh
uh let's see no you do Shrek but with
the seven in place of the uh oh no I
guess it doesn't
it's kind of chill like the H but
um Adam Halbert says I've been stressed
from how the strike has affected my job
wondering if you heard anything on
tomorrow's wjam TP meeting no I'm sorry
I mean just that it's it's happening
which is which is good and and the fact
that you know that the last time they
met it wasn't that long ago so they
obviously have some new some one side or
the other has some new thing they want
to talk about or there would be no point
so we'll give you everything you want
but we get to recreate you in Ai and
torture you for all eternity I mean who
knows but uh but yeah I mean I I think
that the the back and forth discourse uh
of the last few weeks about which shows
can come back like it's wearing on
everybody everyone's fatigued everyone's
tired of this Studios streamers and
actors and writers and so hopefully
we're circling end game if everybody's I
heard something uh depressing sorry to
make it worse uh but it's like even if
they came to an agreement today it still
takes four to six weeks to get a
contract sure it's been signed and then
it's the holidays so No One's Gonna like
I mean that's what worked in December so
it's even in a today we end the strike
scenario it's not gonna start back up
until like January right that was the
original when the strikes were first
starting and and there were all those
articles that were like labor day's
really like we need to get this figured
out by Labor day without having major
impact on 2024 like we are now already
past Labor Day so all of those negative
things have now happened we're basically
we've written off the rest of this year
and now it's about like can we start hit
the ground running in 2024 or is there
even more pain coming next year and like
yeah so we're already looking down the
road like brutal it is
um all right so uh let's see uh well
let's uh two more radar City update
Channel says what kind of Ken would you
be
aren't they all they're all pretty
similar no there's like a
well yeah I guess I mean there's like um
what's the differences between Ken's
they definitely had different
Ken's I feel like I'm more of an Allen
being Allen in a world of Ken's
um yeah there you go uh the little sign
next to my like it's wine o'clock
Stitch that yeah uh and green star will
end with this uh has anyone seen the new
one piece series on Netflix I enjoyed it
very much wondering on your thoughts
tune in next week for honest trailer
commentaries where we will dive into the
good live action uh adaptation of the
good uh anime
long running
um you want to be a pirate that's my
good version of every character on his
trailers
I am a Pirate
[Laughter]
for 17 episodes no Eight Episodes oh it
felt like 17 sometimes but there's
things to like too
um sure we'll figure that out next week
right here in Australia commentaries
talk soon bye-bye
[Music]
thank you